hey wisecrack quarantine jared here
it's been a while since hbo's watchman
concluded and
many of you have noticed that we've been
uncharacteristically quiet
that's because this show is dense sure
it pretty overtly deals with race in
america
but there's just so much going on it's
rife with god complexes
allusions to the graphic novel and
characters reading very specific books
like ernest hemingway's for whom the
bell tolls
it seems like nothing in this show is a
coincidence and we really wanted to get
it right
so what is watchmen trying to say
between the convoluted conspiracies
well we've got an idea to quote our
favorite blue man
nothing ever ends what never ends let's
find out
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of hbo's watchman
and of course spoilers ahead
first a quick recap watchman takes place
over 30 years after the events of alan
moore and dave gibbons graphic novel
so let's start there in the 1980s the
united states and the ussr are on the
verge of annihilating the world in a
nuclear apocalypse
so the world's smartest man adrian white
concocts a plan to avert the war
through fear and sends a giant psionic
squid to attack new york city
killing millions the squid the world
believes is an invader from another
dimension
so everybody unites as one nuclear
apocalypse averted
the history of watchmen's world is very
different from our own before
and after the graphic novel the united
states won the vietnam war
richard nixon was never impeached robert
redford becomes president
and term limits have been abolished good
god
robert redford is still president also
dr manhattan used his god-like
intelligence to invent a bunch of
electronics but
people thought he was giving them cancer
so now the world exists mostly devoid of
things like cell phones and lithium
batteries
watchmen the tv show picks up in modern
day tulsa oklahoma
rorschach who in the graphic novel sent
his journal detailing fight's plot to a
right-wing newspaper
has been mostly dismissed as a crank but
his visage has been taken up by a group
of white supremacists known as the
seventh cavalry
they've been terrorizing the police who
have also taken up masks to shield
their identity within this literal race
war is detective angela abar
a black woman who must learn about her
family's past by odin on her grandpa's
memory pills
also she it is heavily implied becomes
god before we can grasp what the show
means by
nothing we have to understand one of
watchman's recurring motifs
judgment moore and gibbons watchmen
invoke the latin phrase
who watches the watchmen to warn of the
dangers of masked vigilantes taking
justice into their own hands
that is what do people do with
unfettered power
if you're the comedian you gleefully
murder with a smiley badge because
it's kind of funny in the show too the
cruelty and tyranny of individuals
exerting their judgment outside the law
is everywhere vite callously disregards
the life that exists to serve him
creating the creepiest i'm sorry a
father has ever conveyed to his daughter
when he's put on trial for his crimes
the judge is keen to note that a jury of
one's peers
is the cornerstone of a fair trial
before noting you are not his peers
as such i have taken the liberty of
assembling an alternative jury
much more suited to the task
[Music]
the point being one is entitled to be
judged by one's peers
and while vite might consider himself a
quasi-god above these creatures
the judge considers him to be below
humanity the whole problem with
vigilante justice
especially of the masked variety is that
they rob people of the opportunity to be
judged by the legal system or their
peers
but the show is not just interested in
individual vigilantism
but in the vigilantism of mobs in the
show's first scenes a young will reeves
watches a film about a black sheriff who
captures a white cattle thief and rebuts
calls for mob justice
with a plea instead to trust the law
[Music]
this scene is interrupted and we're
shown another kind of mob justice
as white tolsons massacre their black
neighbors after a black man was accused
of assaulting a white woman
one way to answer the question of
vigilante violence is with the work of
sociologist max weber who defines a
state as an entity that claims the
monopoly of the legitimate use of
physical force within a community
in other words i can't just go and rally
my friends to beat up the guy who sold
me a bootleg copy of pokemon gold
nor can i physically coerce him to give
me a refund instead
i have to call the police who as agents
of the state are allowed to use force in
carrying out the law
this is the basic conflict between the
us government and our masked adventurers
as the keen act criminalized vigilantism
but trusting the law and the state's
monopoly of violence
isn't as reeves learns a magical cure to
the ills of the world
you ain't gonna get justice with a badge
wheel reeves
you're gonna get it with that hood one
way to understand this is through
michelle foucault's proposition that
politics is the continuation of war by
other means
foucault was inverting the famous
aphorism that war is merely the
continuation of politics by other means
if for instance the us military's goal
was to defeat the threat of nazism
during world war ii
we can look at the politics of post-war
germany as a continuation of the allied
victory as the country rapidly
denatified of course the show explores a
similar idea with vietnam's statehood
as the police do the role otherwise done
by the u.s military
but the wars don't always have to be
fought with tanks and generals
if we're to consider the historical
armed suppression of america's black
community through lynchings
firebombings etc as a kind of war then
we can see how that war was
institutionalized
into politics in watchmen the tulsa race
massacre
is the war and much of what comes after
is the politics
seeking justice through the law by
becoming a police officer will reeves
soon learns many of his colleagues are
secret white supremacists
shielding their allies from arrest years
later this relationship is made even
more clear by senator joe keane
who more or less admits that he started
a race war to help his presidential
aspirations
where he could use the full power of the
law to keep america's minorities in
their place
you're wrong about cyclops we're not
racist
we're about restoring balance in those
times when our country forgets the
principles upon which it was founded
because the scales have tipped way too
far
and it is extremely difficult to be a
white man in america right now
but well before that he describes the
tension between the police and the
seventh cavalry as a
managed piece to achieve his ends i came
down here and assumed leadership of
these idiots to prevent that
from happening again and my buddy judd
did the same as chief
of police each of us managing our
respective teams so that we could
maintain the peace
as fuco writes the role of political
power is perpetually to use a sort of
silent
war to reinscribe that relationship of
force and to re-inscribe it in
institutions
economic inequalities language and even
the bodies of individuals
even the members of cyclops implicitly
share this view of politics but with
themselves as the victims
with redford as president the members of
cyclops feel that they've
lost their war that policies like
redfordations are just a way of
as keen describes putting the white man
down first
he took her guns and then
he made us say sorry over and over again
sorry sorry for the
alleged sins of those who died decades
before we were born
sorry for the color of our skin in other
words watchmen
is not just about the dangers of
vigilante justice whether from lynch
mobs or war crime committing comedians
but about how war and violence can
become embedded
in the law and when violence gets
embedded in the law
it can often evade judgment as a result
after all
justice is blind speaking of judgment if
you weren't sure this was at the top of
damon lindelof's mind there's one song
that keeps coming up that you may have
noticed during vites trial
that's the lacrimosa from mozart's
requiem let's translate those lyrics
full of tears will be that day when from
the ashes shall arise the guilty man to
be judged
therefore spare him oh god you know just
a song about being judged at the end of
the world
the end is nigh it plays when lady true
tells angela dr manhattan is in tulsa
when wade discovers the cyclops hideout
but most notably plays when blake
arrests vite and he says
who do you think you are hold judgment
over me the point being
whether godlike actual gods or just
people dressed up like batman
many of our characters feel like their
fellow humans are inadequate to judge
them
keen and true want to become god for
just that reason
true because she thinks she can
unilaterally solve the world's problems
and
keen ostensibly to re-establish the
glory days of white supremacy
white's unilateral decision to save the
world from nuclear apocalypse is unknown
to the world
and thus not capable of being judged
i saved the world from
[Music]
nuclear armageddon
aside from you and a select few
nobody knows so too are the actions of
captain metropolis hood of justice
rorschach or lube guy
a mask in the world of watchmen shields
its wearer from the judgment of others
which makes judd's recitation of the
latin phrase who watches the watchmen to
his masked police force
so incredibly ironic squeeze custodian
ipsos custodies
especially as they reply
cyclops conspiracy aside watchman isn't
shy about how such a culture
quickly leads to an out-of-control
police state where torture and
rightlessness are the norm
i want my lawyer yeah we really don't
have to do that with terrorists when
certain kinds of violence become
embedded in the law
the state can effectively shield
themselves from judgment whether you're
throwing someone in the trunk of your
car
there's a guy in my trunk or exploding
people's heads on behalf of the federal
government
but if hiding one's identity protects
one from the judgment of their peers
so can hiding one's history one of
white's sources of power is his ability
to hide his past crimes from the public
he doesn't need a mask to avoid judgment
but this idea isn't simply limited to
vite
we learned through pedipedia the
supplementary hbo material as collected
by agent pedi
that fog dancing a book vike reads in
prison
is about american soldiers who would
dispose of evidence of american war
crimes
he claims he reads it because it's about
loneliness but maybe he relates to the
themes of covering up one's crimes
you wouldn't understand
[Music]
it's about loneliness if white is hiding
his history to avoid judgment
who or what else is to fully grasp that
we have to look at watchmen's one true
god
dr manhattan part two nothing ever ends
while dr manhattan isn't even seen until
the penultimate episode his worldview is
critical to understand the show
in episode 8 he explains his unique
relationship to time
it's not a flow of events from past to
present but something he experiences
simultaneously
how long has it been for you 24 years
41 days and 13 hours
for me it's happening right now yes yes
i remember
with this premise the show cuts back and
forth between the doctor's childhood
fleeing the nazis his meeting of angela
and their
future together the show wants us to
think about history like dr manhattan
without the idea of before i don't
experience the concept of before in
other words a view of history in which
nothing ever ends
history is not dead but alive in our
current moment
and the show constantly explores how the
past continues into the present
we see the fictional events of the
graphic novel trickle into every detail
of life
in a nod to the final pages of the
graphic novel angela and her grandmother
eat at a chain called burgers and
borscht
a cultural melding made possible by the
threat of extra-dimensional annihilation
at a dinner party kids make a game of
reciting the u.s presidents
moving to where watchmen history
diverges and nixon never resigns and is
succeeded by gerald ford and robert
redford
it relishes in the tiniest of details
imagining that steven spielberg made
schindler's list
not about the holocaust but about the
giant squid attack
the movie's black and white so the red
really pops you know
and the girls stumbling around herald
square
walking under the tentacles through all
the dead bodies
and she's scared or suggesting to the
viewer that john grisham has become a
supreme court justice
of course if the alternate history gives
way to the alternate present
so too does real history give way to the
real present
aside from small easter eggs it cannot
be understated the insane level of
detail watchmen puts into thinking about
history
blake's sidekick petey has a phd in
history i wrote my
graduate thesis on the police strike of
77.
will's wife june is a reporter at the
new york amsterdam news
why are you writing your story about me
because the amsterdam says a negro cadet
making the forces big news one of new
york's most influential and oldest
african-american newspapers that was
especially active in covering the civil
rights movement and chronicled the rise
of malcolm x
lady true is named after the vietnamese
historical figure who fought to resist
the chinese state of eastern wu
as it occupied vietnam and is quoted by
her mother when she steals vitexy
[Music]
um
key events happen in a literal museum
and the us treasury secretary is real
life historian henry lewis gates jr
and here we get back to dr manhattan
because just as manhattan's experience
of time
seamlessly jumps from one moment in time
to another so too does the show
like manhattan laughing at a
six-month-old joke
this angela must be quite something six
months ago she's telling me i have a
fantastic imagination the show
interjects moments of history to show
their connectedness
the show often juxtaposes similar
objects from different times
this is most explicitly done while
angela is overdosing on nostalgia
as angela remembers being given a badge
by a vietnamese police officer the show
quickly cuts to the badge of bass reeves
in the 1920s
to will reeves receiving his badge over
a decade later to the blood-spattered
badge of chief crawford over half a
century later
when a police officer puts a sack over a
suspect's head angela flashes back to
the memory of will putting on the sack
from his almost lynching
or as will reeves sees a police car
drive by two corpses from the tulsa race
massacre drag behind
through these techniques the show asks
the viewer to consider
past and present acts of racism as one
continual legacy
other examples in the show are stretched
out between episodes
in tulsa we see a molotov cocktail
thrown through a shop window
an event that repeats itself years later
at a jewish deli
angela's makeup closely resemble hooded
justices but it blackens her skin
instead of whitening it and a racist
bank ad we see unveiled by captain
metropolis is later hung
in the 7th cavalry hideout much like the
graphic novel
the show uses the clock motif to ask the
viewer to consider the idea of time
and how not unlike a constructed watch
is a series of meticulous cogs that
create an illusory march
from past to present this
counter-intuitive approach to time
seems critical to one of watchman's
biggest themes historiography
that is the writing of history put
simply debates around historiography can
let us ask questions like
what is or was considered historically
important enough to discuss in the first
place
a lot of history involves finding facts
about individual events and discerning a
narrative in them and that's where
things can get especially tricky
so was the holocaust some anomaly of
european history
or was the extermination of jews gypsies
and others
deeply influenced by practices and
ideologies birthed by europeans as they
colonized africa
as philosopher hannah arendt or other
historians argue
same event different story watchman's
own show within a show
american hero story like the comics
novel within a novel under the hood
serves as a reminder of what happens to
history when sensationalism meets an
utter disregard for the truth pd's
complaints about its accuracy aside
that show is garbage
it's full of historical inaccuracies it
manages to tell the story of hooded
justice
while glibly ignoring the lack of
information about the person behind the
mask
in this case what the show portrays is a
fun romp of a robbery busting
was actually a black man fighting the
clan to drive the point home
the scene more or less plays in reverse
hinting how the show got it in
historical terms
ass backwards whereas fictional hood of
justice breaks into the store from the
window
to save the day from some nameless thugs
the real hooded justice jumped out the
window when fleeing from a prominent
white supremacist
much of the history of watchmen like its
fictional critique of american hero
story
focuses on exactly what's been forgotten
or deliberately ignored
in the mainstream writing of real
american history
throughout the show we're presented with
events in newspaper clippings that one
might easily dismiss
as part of the show's intricate
mythology but time after time
they're not they actually happen hooded
justice has pinned up articles declaring
nazis marched through streets of long
island and
22 000 nazis hold rally in madison
square garden
the latter being a reference to the
german american bund rally in new york
the insinuation is that support for
nazism in america is intricately linked
to the fictional cyclops with its white
supremacist mission
of course many people have discussed the
show's opening which portrays the event
of the tulsa race massacre where
america's wealthiest black neighborhood
was destroyed by a mob of white tolsons
as nbc reported many people were
surprised to learn that this was
in fact real as it is not often
discussed in most history textbooks
even the small details the presence of
black gis who had served in world war 1
in tulsa and the bombing by airplanes
are all historically accurate later we
see german propaganda during world war 1
that asks black gis why they would fight
for a country in which they were
do second-class enjoy the same rights as
the white people do in america
are obviously rather treated over the
second-class citizens
the leaflet which a young william finds
in his father's coat reflects real
german propaganda from the time
what's more a newspaper on the ground
bears the real headline from the tulsa
tribune in the lead-up to the massacre
the article even makes its way to modern
day as is seen in the greenwood museum
the museum is helmed not only by a
prominent historian but a man who
sparked a national outrage about racial
profiling after being arrested for
breaking into his own home
there's a pretty fitting moment when
will reeves confronts judd about the
clan robe in his closet
again the history is no accident the
clan often collaborated with police
departments especially during the civil
rights era
the clan had helped elect a white racist
named eugene
bull connor as birmingham's police chief
in florida for instance the fbi knew too
that in the 1940s and 50s
county sheriff's openly joined the clan
writes gilbert king in his book
devil in the grove during the tulsa
massacre itself
some police officers straight up
deputized members of the lynch mob
of course the regular involvement of
police departments with lynch mobs in
the clan
are simultaneously either ignored or in
judd's case
part of his heritage i have a right to
keep it
it's my legacy to which william replies
was so proud of your legacy
would you hide it like white america's
history has been shielded from judgment
alan moore though he's had sharp words
against the hbo show has made similar
statements about the history of masked
heroes
saying a good argument can be made for
dw griffith's birth of a nation as the
first american superhero movie
and the point of origin for all those
capes and masks griffith's film which
glorified the clan
is credited with helping the rebirth of
the kkk in america
then of course there's the more subtle
or maybe just coincidental historical
parallels
the cyclops mesmerism encourages african
americans to harm and hate each other
do not bring harm to any white man woman
or child
only each other which seems like a loose
fictionalization of the idea as argued
by thinker bell hooks
that the entire world of advertising and
mass media in general
which sends both the covert and overt
message that blackness is negative
is part of the propaganda machinery of
shaming
the seventh cavalry members live in a
place called nixonville
obviously after the president but nixon
might be of specific importance to the
show's fascination with history
whereas pandering to white racist was a
favorite pastime of democrats like
george wallace
nixon and his political allies were able
to rest votes from the traditionally
democrat voting south to the republican
party
by stirring up racist fears in white
voters to quote nixon strategist kevin
phillips in 1970
the more negroes who register as
democrats in the south the sooner the
negrophobe whites will quit the
democrats and become republicans
that's where the votes are the idea that
the 7th cavalry are not some modern
anomaly but the product of specific
history
is further driven home by smaller
details their name derives from the u.s
army regiment famously commanded by
general custer during the great sioux
war of 1876
a war brought on by america's desire for
gold in native american territory
at one point judd even sends a pager
message reading
little bighorn in reference to custer's
famous last stand
the idea that they're driven by the
historical legacy of manifest destiny
and white supremacy in america
is furthered with small details like the
painting martial feats of comanche
horsemanship
a george catlin painting that in
pedipedia we learn was given by senator
keane to remind judd
how formidable our savage enemies can be
the philosophy of watchmen might just be
coyly written right there in the episode
4 title
if you don't like my story write your
own borrowing from a quote from author
chinwa chebe
it's worth mentioning achebe's famous
novel things fall apart is about the
arrival of european colonizers in
nigeria
achebe as scholar john tima notes was
interested in recuperating the image of
africa in contrast to european writers
like joseph conrad
who portrayed it as a place of savagery
and barbarism
through the character of angela we see
watchman's approach to history as she
learns the truth of her past and how it
has deeply affected her
her whole journey is as will describes
it to learn where she came from
i wanted to meet you and show you where
you came from she not only has to
grapple with the trauma that defines her
but how that trauma seems rooted in her
genealogy in a different episode lady
true tells two farmers that
legacy isn't in land it's in blood
passed to us from our ancestors and buy
us to our children
angela learns that the legacy she
inherited was that of a granddaughter of
a tulsa massacre survivor
elsewhere we're told about genetic
trauma in a support group i read an
article
here's this thing
genetic drama while the psychic squid
mass murder is fictional the concept of
genetic trauma is the real and ongoing
hypothesis that stressful or traumatic
experiences might alter the genetic
expression of their children
small studies of the children of
holocaust survivors for instance suggest
biological changes in their children
but if squid survivors can beget their
trauma to their kin in watchmen's eyes
so too can the victims of racist
violence when angela foley learns her
history by taking nostalgia
it almost breaks her mind but by the end
angela learns not to suppress her
personal trauma
as will explains the hood
when i put it on you from what i felt
anger yeah that's what i thought too
but it wasn't
let me fear hurt
[Music]
you can't heal under a mascara
wounds need hair and what about angela's
heavily implied apotheosis
for a show fixated on the monstrous
deeds of characters trying to become god
it seems strange to have the protagonist
become one but if we think back to time
one of the show's primary motifs and how
dr manhattan experiences it
maybe angela's arc is to experience the
past present
and future as one to understand as the
show reminds us
that nothing ever ends but what do you
think wisecrack
let us know in the comments shout out to
all our awesome patrons who support the
channel in our podcast
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and we'll catch y'all next time
[Music]
peace
you